you might want to grab the tissues
because vanessa bryant just got
an unexpected special gift from her late
husband
kobe bryant on her birthday and it's the
sweetest thing
ever our responsibility is to always
inspire
vanessa turned 38 on tuesday and hit up
instagram to tell fans that she recently
found a letter from kobe
that she had never opened the envelope
was addressed to
the love of my life from to poppy
vanessa said that she intentionally
waited until her b day to open the
letter
explaining quote it gave me something to
look forward to
she also added that she was missing the
love of my life and my sweet little
mamacita
kobe and their 13 year old daughter
gianna died in a helicopter crash in
calabasas california in january
alongside seven other victims vanessa
and the late nba star were married for
18 years and she was no stranger to a
romantic gesture from her man
at his memorial in february she revealed
that he once gave her the famous blue
dress and shoes
worn by rachel mcadams in the notebook
as a valentine's day present
that blue dress the couple would have
celebrated their 19th wedding
anniversary on april 18th
and to honor the day vanessa shared this
throwback pic
writing my king my heart my best friend
a source told et that vanessa planned to
celebrate the day with their daughters
seventeen-year-old natalia
three-year-old bianca and
nine-month-old capri but their
anniversary isn't the only bittersweet
occasion that's popped up for the bryant
fan
last friday vanessa took to instagram
with a special message for their late
daughter on what would have been her
14th birthday
writing in part quote you are part of my
soul forever i miss you so much every
day
in april vanessa shared a pic of gigi
smiling while wearing her number two
jersey on the basketball court
she's a stone cold killer out there yeah
yeah at both ends of the floor
she plays defense as well as offense man
she competes also in april the wnba
honored gianna and two other victims of
the helicopter crash
by selecting them as honorary draft
picks
it would have been a dream come true for
her she captioned the post
quote you deserve to live a long healthy
and happy life
i wish i could hold you and tell you how
proud i am of you
she worked tirelessly every single day
she wanted to be one of the greatest
athletes of all time
just like her daddy
so thank you thank you for honoring my
little girl e.t recently spoke to fellow
basketball
great magic johnson who gave us an
update on how vanessa and the girls are
doing
they're living their life they're
they're having a good time
and i think kobe would have wanted that
right for them to go on
live a great life and just have enjoy
yourself
and vanessa's the reason for that and i
think she's got a great village around
her people around her
to give her that support part of that
support system
vanessa's friend lala anthony who told
et
she couldn't be more proud of the way
the mom of three is
handling it all i talked to her every
single day and just you know continue to
pray for her and stay positive for her
she
i tell her every day she's the strongest
woman i know and
i'm really really proud of just how
she's handling everything and just
want to continue to be there you know as
much as i can for her as a friend she's
just
an amazing and amazing human being just
just amazing